نعم ، هناك أشخاص سود في اليمن ، نعم ،
هناك أشخاص سود في تركيا ،
نعم عندما تذهب وتزور كيتو ،
يجب أن تسافر إلى الشمال وتذهب
لرؤية المجتمع الأفريقي الإكوادوري المعروف
باسم إزميرالدا ، قابل
مارتينيك لويس صانع المحتوى
والتنوع ومستشار السفر الذي
يدافع عن المزيد من
التضمين في صناعة السفر بصفتي
مسافرًا متعطشًا ،
سأسافر إلى بلدان في
كل مكان وسأرى أشخاصًا
يشبهونني ووجهاتي المفضلة أفكر
لماذا لا يعرف الأشخاص الآخرون الذين
يشبهونني أن هؤلاء الأشخاص  موجودون هنا
بمنحة ريادة الأعمال ، قام لويس
بنشر كتاب abc travel green book ذاتيًا
كدليل لمجتمعات الأعمال المملوكة للسود
ووجهات السفر
في الولايات المتحدة وخارجها ،
وهو مستوحى من الكتاب الأخضر لسائقي السيارات الزنجي
الذي أدرج
الأماكن الآمنة للسائحين السود أثناء
السفر في
كان هذا صحيحًا عندما بدأت العائلات السوداء
في الحصول على السيارات
وأرادوا قضاء الإجازات
إما في طريقك  أعرف من الجنوب
إلى الغرب الأوسط أو من الشرق إلى
الغرب ،
أردت أن أفعل نفس النوع من الأشياء
ولكني أردت أن أفعل ذلك على
المستوى الدولي ،
لويس جزء من جيل جديد من
منشئي محتوى السفر الذين
يطالبون بمزيد من التضمين في
التواصل التسويقي والتمثيل للفئات
المهمشة يوم الثلاثاء ، لاحظت وجود
انفصال بين ما تنشره بعض
العلامات التجارية للسفر على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي وما كانوا يفعلونه بالفعل
لممارسة التنوع حول 17 من
زملائي وقد اجتمعت معًا وقلت
علينا أن نفعل شيئًا
حيال هذا  لأنه لم يعد من المقبول
بالنسبة لهم
التصرف بطريقة معينة على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ولكن
ليس لإثبات ذلك
، شكلت لويس وزملاؤها
تحالف السفر الأسود وحملة
السحب لمحاسبة العلامات التجارية والشركات الخاصة بالسفر ،
فهناك الكثير من الموارد المتاحة
هناك للقيام بنفس الشيء مع
العثور على الشركات المملوكة للسود في
وجهتك ولكن مع الكتاب الأخضر ،
قمت بهذا العمل من أجلهم ، لذلك عندما
قل المساءلة ، أنا معجب الآن ، أنت
حقًا حقًا ليس لديك أي عذر
لأنني وضعت كل شيء في كتاب
العام الماضي تحدثت لويس في
قمة السفر السنوية في facebook لربط أفضل
العلامات التجارية للسفر بالمجتمعات الشاملة
عبر الإنترنت
في القمة التي قدمت
تنوعها وسفرها  بطاقة تقرير
بعد تقييم 55 علامة تجارية بارزة للسفر من
أجل الشمولية
لقد كنت على مدار السنوات القليلة الماضية
أعلم المجتمع
حول هذه القصص أو تعليم
المجتمعات حول هذه الجيوب حيث
يمكنك العثور على
أشخاص سود ، فإن جولة التراث الأسود في أمستردام هي
واحدة من تلك الجيوب التي اكتشفها لويس
قبل نشر
الكتاب وهو الآن في دليلها ، يذهب الجميع
إلى أمستردام ويذهبون إلى منطقة الضوء الأحمر
دون أن يدركوا أنك
تتجول في منطقة الضوء الأحمر ،
كل ما عليك فعله هو البحث لأعلى
وترى وجوهًا سوداء على المباني لأن
هذا  كيف أظهر الناس
أنهم أثرياء من خلال إظهار أن
لديهم عبيدًا
كثيرًا من الوجود الأسود
تم الحفاظ على التاريخ الاستعماري
جيدًا في تاريخنا المعماري ،
وأعتقد أنه من المدهش أنها
اتخذت هذه المبادرة
لأنني أعتقد أنك تعرف سنوات عديدة على
أنها مصدر إلهام بالطبع
لكتابها المستوحى من
الكتاب الأخضر
أم في الولايات المتحدة ، فإنه يفتح
الوصول
للأشخاص ذوي البشرة السمراء والمسافرين أو
الحلفاء ، وهذا للمسافرين في
كل مكان الذين يسمون أنفسهم حليفًا
يقولون إنهم يريدون دعم
الأصوات السوداء ورعاية
الأعمال التجارية السوداء ، يساعدك هذا الكتاب في
تحديد مكان
هؤلاء الأشخاص بالضبط
المجتمعات وهذه الأماكن